figurez vous que les vedettes de cinéma
elle aussi prennent des vacances et
aujourd'hui nous sommes venu surprendre
en plein inactivité notre gorille
nationale lino ventura peut-être vous
êtes vous déjà demandé qu'elle pouvait
bien être l'emploi du temps de ces gens
là au repos qui va t'il que font-ils
bref comment passe-t-il leurs vacances
je baignais les enfants ou alors je pars
en mer jaune la pêche
le soir j'ai assuré une bande de rigolos
qui est là avec la caisse de jouer aux
boules en bois local
décontraction totale on parle de la
pêche parce que je pense que la pêche en
main surtout pratiqué avec paul unis
c'est quelque chose que kita c'est
énorme et que les jeunes connaissent pas
et nazis difficile alors expliqué
d'ailleurs le reste que c'est difficile
je trouve que paul parent extraordinaire
un bateau si la lumière et puis enfin il
a des méthodes extraordinaire
comme nous avons respecté l'ordre
chronologique des emplois du temps de
line où vous allez pouvoir constater que
la vision du comédien les arts est
encore un mythe qui s'effondre
après la pétanque ça aussi c'est sacré
casse-croûte les vacances en paix tant
que c'est pas possible ça moi je le
conçois tonio par là c'est ici qu'il
faut jouer
voici donc le point culminant de la
journée
vous constaterez que les reculs du
cinéma français ne redoute pas l'effort
physique à la perche tombe avant eux
je ne commence pas à faire ta tabac je
me regarde 2 qu'est ce que tu paris bref
comme vous voyez une journée de vacances
de lino ventura ressemble étrangement à
n'importe quelle journée de vacances de
monsieur tout le monde
dans le fond ces gens là ne sont pas
tellement différents de nous
il a été pendant trente jours au poisson
pourrit par 30 des vacances que je
trouve formidable